one day my son is uh in soccer practice
my wife calls and says babe they just
kicked him out of the camp he knocked
the kid out in front of the coach he
punched him the kid fell he knocked him
out they say he can't come back here
anymore so and I hear my son in the back
screaming dad you know I'm not afraid of
the truth he punched me first I said
I'll go fight for you well you better be
telling me the truth I'm telling you the
truth and you see the tears coming down
I called the owners I said hey I heard
you guys kick my son out we did he
punched a kid we can't have that kind of
behavior I said do you guys have cameras
there we do I want to go watch the
camera and see who hit who first 2 hours
nobody calls 3 hours they call me your
son is right he got punched first and he
reacted and he knocked him out we've
asked the other kid to be gone for a
week your son is welcome to come back
but I personally wanted to call you to
apologize as he didn't know to apologize
to me I don't care you don't offend me
you need to apologize to my son